marc lavergne directeur de recherche au
cnrs et spécialiste de la corne de
l'afrique
bonsoir marc lavergne merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france
ces 17 années de guerre un traité de
paix qui est signée aujourd'hui trois
cent mille morts deux millions et demi
de déplacés
quels sont les enjeux de cet accord de
paix écoutez le sujet qui a été présenté
déjà assez complet effectivement et il
montre également les incertitudes nées
de ceux de cet accord qui est parrainée
quand il faut pas beaucoup de pays
africains par l'union africaine qui a
été aidé aussi par tous les pays voisins
y compris de l'ethiopie le soudan du sud
est
on voit bien aussi cette hésitation
qu'il y a à prendre pour argent comptant
cet accord qui a été signé entre
certains des groupes rebelles mais pas
tous et qui a mis un an à être signé
alors qu'on pourrait penser que le
soulèvement démocratique de l'an dernier
et qui a mis fin à la dictature de mal
pire en avril 2019 et qui a donné
naissance à ce gouvernement de
transition au mois de septembre de
l'année dernière à un an de négociations
pour arriver à ça c'est à dire des
déclarations de bonnes intentions mais
finalement concrètement les problèmes
qui ont été évoqués ceux des personnes
des millions de gens qui ont été
déplacées depuis maintenant plus de près
de vingt ans de leur village vient on ne
sait pas très bien comment ça va
s'opérer des groupes rebelles ont refusé
eux de se joindre à cet accord
donc il ya encore beaucoup
d'incertitudes et puis il y avait jean
paul oublier des groupes maintenant
rebelles qui sont actifs en libye par
exemple de chaque côté qui d'autre qui
ont fait la guerre au yémen au service
de l'arabie saoudite
donc il ya beaucoup de facteurs
d'instabilité à l'extérieur du soudan
qui impacte la le règlement pacifique de
cette situation et puis une question
financière
parce que comment rétablir l'équilibré
entre le centre du soudan la capitale la
vallée du nil qui sont privilégiés tout
ce ce centre arabo musulman si vous
voulez du soudan et puis ces régions
périphériques qui elles sont plus se
sentent plus africaine sont musulmanes
pour la plupart mais pas seulement qui
demande la séparation de la religion et
de l'état
le tout ça sur le papier c'est facile à
écrire et à signer c'est beaucoup plus
difficile à mettre en oeuvre
ça ne se fait pas autour d'une table ça
se fait avec un long processus de
travail auprès de la société soudanaise
que ça soit celle du centre qui domine
l'ensemble du pays
même si elle est en faveur de la
démocratie
comme l a fait tomber la dictature mais
aussi ces gens qui en ont pris les armes
il y a maintenant une dizaine ou une
vingtaine d'années vous allez parler 17
ans mais ça peut être plus pour certains
groupes
eh bien ces gens là ne donneront pas
leur arme ne s'arrêteront pas de se
battre si un minimum d'égalité ou
d'applications d'entreprise oeuvre or le
soudan est un pays en faillite qui n'a
pas les moyens financiers de développer
des écoles des hôpitaux des
infrastructures de créer des routes de
donner cette égalité des chances aux
gens de ces régions périphériques
donc voilà beaucoup d'incertitudes
beaucoup de d'inquiétude dans un
complexe
enfin un contexte international qui est
très troublé ne le sait on a parlé à
l'instant de l'arménie donc les pays
occidentaux les pays les grandes
puissances ne sont peut-être pas là
comme parrain de cet accord pour
s'assurer que le soudan regagne
définitivement sorte de stabilité ce
qu'il faut évidemment c'est de l'argent
on sait le soudan subi une grave crise
économique et n'a plus la manne
pétrolière qui l'avait lorsque le soudan
du sud faisait partie du pays qu'elle
est qu'elles sont et longue
les enjeux pour rapatrier justement
c'est ces réfugiés désarmer les milices
il faut il faut de l'argent et qui va le
donner cet argent il faut nécessairement
d'argent vous savez les gens étaient
dans des camps de déplacés
alors le confort des camps de déplacés
n'est pas extraordinaire mais il est
toujours supérieur à celui que les gens
connaissaient dans leur village
autrefois ils ont l'eau courante ils ont
des écoles ils ont la ville à proximité
avec des possibilités d'emploi après
vingt ans comment retourner dans les
villages qui sont occupés par d'anciens
nomades qui sont occupés par des gens
qui ont brûlé ces villages
et qui les ont chassés comment
indemniser ceux qui doivent partir pour
laisser venir ceux qui vont rentrer et
leur fournir le minimum de services
auxquels ils sont maintenant habitués
bien qu'ils soient parqués dans des
camps de déplacés voilà déjà une des
questions alors la question du
financement ce qui est évoqué pour
combler les dettes du soudan c'est de
l'aide américaine par exemple ou
européenne cd presse et des dons mais ça
suffira déjà difficilement un rang à
rembourser les dettes du soudan mais
certainement pas à financer la
reconstruction du pays
ça c'est une question ce sont des
régions riches parce qu'il y a de l'or
au darfour
il ya du pétrole dans d'autres régions
il ya des minerais souhait le soudan est
une sorte de lieu de compétition des
chinois des américains des gens du golfe
de beaucoup de puissance qu'ils sentent
qu'il ya beaucoup de richesse à
exploiter dans ce pays
mais finalement les gens se préoccupent
assez peu de la situation
disons au sécuritaire en tout cas de la
population et salses et la voici que cet
accord de paix
à un petit peu arrangé les choses des
relations avec les etats-unis se sont
quelque peu resserré grâce à grâce à
cette ce départ en tout cas d'omar el
béchir oui je pense qu'effectivement il
ya eu un engagement depuis d'ailleurs le
la chute demeure el béchir des états
unis un engagement aussi mitigé de
l'arabie saoudite des émirats arabes
unis pour admettre cette coexistence de
l'armée et puis delà des civils qui sont
des partis politiques laïcs et religieux
mais aussi d'une troisième force on voit
que le chef des mercenaires qui a
déstabilisé le soudan et qui aujourd'hui
est finalement le l'homme fort du soudan
un monsieur aimetti mohamed hamdan
zagallo qu'on a vu sur les photos c'est
lui qui est le parrain de cet accord
parce qu'il est originaire de tribus du
darfour qui ont provoqué tous ces
massacres et tous ces pillages mais
aujourd'hui c'est l'homme qui est
l'homme de l'entente avec les rebelles
parce qu'il les connaît il les a
combattus et tout ça est quand même
assez incertain parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui domine toutes les mines
d'or du pays qui a les clés du coffre si
vous voulez et qui veut prendre le
pouvoir à khartoum à la place de ce
gouvernement civil qui fait ce qu'il
peut avec les moyens qu'il peut qui a
réussi à signer cet accord
mais encore une fois derrière il ya
beaucoup de faits il ya l'armée qui veut
pas perdre ses privilèges y compris
financiers et puis à ces groupes de
mercenaires qui aujourd'hui s'activent
dans toute la région et voit le soudan
comme une source de richesse beaucoup
plus que comme un peuple dont il s'agit
d'assurer le progrès et la prospérité
merci beaucoup marc lavergne d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france